the 2020 adaptation of royal dolls the
witches is a sinister delight
but there's a whole lot in this magical
movie that probably sails right over
younger viewers heads
keep watching to discover the details
that only the grown-ups in the audience
will notice
our hero who is unnamed in the book but
identified as charlie in the film begins
his tale in the last month of 1968.
for most kids this setting probably just
comes across as nebulous olden times but
adults should recognize that year for
its historical significance involving
the american civil rights movement
this struggle isn't present in the book
but it became very relevant once it was
decided to center this adaptation around
black characters in the american south
on april 4 1968 civil rights leader
martin luther king jr was assassinated
riots broke out in the wake of his death
placing more pressure than ever on
president lyndon b
johnson to enact change april 11 saw the
passing of the fair housing act which
prevents housing discrimination on the
basis of race sex
national origin and religion while the
witches never explicitly engages with
these events setting its story in 1968
nevertheless unavoidably adds a new
layer of complexity and tension to the
tale
in both the book and the film charlie
learns everything he knows about witches
from his grandmother
however the movie never explains how she
came to be quite so knowledgeable about
supernatural creatures
all she tells charlie is that when she
was a child she saw her friend alice
transform into a chicken after accepting
a piece of candy from a strange lady she
later learned was the grand high witch
but that encounter didn't teach grandma
that witches are bald under their wigs
and hats that they have claws and a
heightened sense of smell
and that they don't have toes
furthermore the entire reason she and
charlie pack up and head to a hotel
is because she insists that once a witch
sets her sights on a child she'll never
give up looking for them
also even though she saw the grand high
witch when she was a child she doesn't
appear to be constantly living in fear
of her
why didn't the grand high witch pursue
her did grandma manage to repel her
somehow
the movie never gives us answers to
these questions but whatever those
answers are we're sure that backstory is
interesting
when grandma realizes that a witch is
after her grandson she calls in a favor
with her cousin
who spent three decades as the executive
chef at the grand orleans imperial
island hotel
it is according to grandma the swankiest
hotel in all of alabama
furthermore the clientele consists
entirely of rich white people which is
why grandma believes they'll be safe
there
once they arrive at the hotel grandma's
words take on additional meaning
the grand orleans imperial island hotel
isn't a real place but there's no
mistaking that it's meant to resemble a
converted plantation home
this immediately calls to mind america's
history of slavery which forced black
people to work for rich white people and
endure endless abuse that was enabled in
large part by not enough people making a
fuss
this is a parallel to what happens in
the movie that children might not catch
but adults absolutely will
all members of the hotel staff seen in
the witches are black while all the
guests except for grandma and charlie
are white
when grandma first pulls up in front of
the hotel the bellhop is initially
confused why she's there
and is surprised to hear that she's a
guest once he realizes that she's
serious he seems delighted and refuses a
tip as he takes her bags
this dynamic might go over younger
viewers heads but adults are sure to
grasp its significance
later on once grandma has taken the
grand high witch's case full of money
she makes a point of giving every member
of the hotel staff a 100
tip on her way out the door for adults
who understand the racial power dynamics
that would have been at play in 1968
alabama grandma's generosity is a
kindness as much as it is a triumph
there's a camaraderie between her and
the staff that the other guests don't
have
and their actions toward each other
communicate an unspoken acknowledgement
of it
despite being on opposite sides of the
hotel hierarchy they're all part of the
same community
after grandma receives the key to her
room the hotel manager spots her and
gets a suspicious look in his eye
once he learns who she is his expression
clears but even then he still attempts
to put her down
first he holds her key away from her
while prattling on about her room
ignoring her coughing fit he then leans
down to tell charlie
adults won't miss the unmistakable
racial power dynamics at play in the
scene
if grandma had been white the manager
surely wouldn't have given her presence
in the lobby a second thought
and even though he smiles throughout
their encounter his actions and language
convey that he is making sure that she
knows that he is the one in control of
the situation and that she and charlie
should feel grateful to be allowed in at
all
it's a superficially benign encounter
with a very ugly undercurrent
in addition to the real world bigotry
present in the scene it's also loaded
with ironic tension
since a guest who really shouldn't be
allowed into the hotel are greeted
warmly immediately afterwards
when grandma and charlie check in
they're told that their room number is
766 which turns out to be directly above
the grand high witch's suite in 666
these numbers have more significance
than just their locations within the
hotel
in the bible 666 is a number associated
with the antichrist in the book of
revelation
which certainly adds some additional
meaning to grandma's explanation that
witches are demons
while there's not much more religious
subtext besides that and the witches the
room numbers are certainly meant to
raise eyebrows
driving home that the grand high witch
is indeed meant to be the ultimate
embodiment of evil
it's a pretty dark reference to making a
film targeted towards children
but unless the kids watching are
particularly well versed in the bible's
apocalyptic literature they're not
likely to think of 666 as anything more
than just a number
after being turned into a mouse
alongside his friend bruno charlie
hatches a plot with grandma to use the
mousemaker potion against the witches by
putting it in their pea soup
they ultimately pull it off as dozens of
witches get dramatically transformed
into grotesque rats in the middle of
dinner
despite witnessing this transformation
as it happens the hotel staff
immediately sets about exterminating
their guests
meanwhile the other guests panic with
most of them running while screaming
from the dining room
although the audience knows that the
sudden presence of vermin in the dining
room isn't due to any negligence on the
part of the hotel the other guests have
no way of knowing that
combined with the inevitable news that
an entire group staying at the hotel has
gone missing
the story of an out-of-control rodent
infestation will likely lead to a steep
decline in business
if not a complete shutdown the grand
high witch has a trunk full of crisp 100
bills in her room her assurance to the
other witch is that they don't have to
worry about money because she has it
taken care of is readily accepted by her
acolytes
of course she's got piles of cash they
seem to think she's the grand high witch
after all
but adults in the audience may wonder
exactly where that money came from
as it seems that witches can't just
conjure cash out of thin air
the film implies that the grand high
witch doesn't age as evidenced by
grandma's earlier encounter with her so
it's possible she's just been
fastidiously frugal all these years
her decision to go with whichever soup
is cheapest for dinner certainly nods to
that
but those bills seem a little too fresh
to represent years worth of savings
or even a large cash withdrawal from the
bank is it counterfeit
did she steal it did she create it using
magic that the other witches can't use
and perhaps most importantly are those
bills traceable and while grandma's use
of them draw the attention of law
enforcement
from the perspective outside the hotel
both bruno's parents and grandma go on
vacation with their children and then
come back without them
what's more neither is likely to file a
missing person report since they know
the kids are mice now
both grandma and the jenkins family will
probably proceed with life as usual just
without children
but this is bound to raise some
questions once other people realize that
kids are missing
from charlie's point of view he and
grandma are about to begin traveling the
world to hunt down more witches
but the reality might not end up being
so simple it's possible that grandma
knows the authorities may eventually
start wondering what happened to charlie
especially since she gained custody of
him so soon before he disappeared
and she may also realize that while the
two of them are indeed really hunting
witches together they're also on the lam
she could try explaining what happened
but it's not likely anyone would believe
her
especially considering the windfall of
cash she recently procured
the witches ends with an older version
of charlie teaching a group of child
recruits about witches but it's never
explained where these kids come from
where their parents are or how they'll
be able to travel all over the world
hunting witches
it's also hard to tell exactly where
charlie's giving his presentation
it doesn't appear to be a school
auditorium or gymnasium which rules out
some of the very places it might be
reasonable for charlie and grandma to
have access to a large group of children
although even if that were the case one
would have to wonder where all the
teachers are
it seems most likely that they're in
some sort of basement or bunker but in
that case how did they round up enough
children to fill it
are they out at playgrounds recruiting
kids to their cause are the parents
involved in any way or did all these
kids sneak out of their homes without
their knowledge
and perhaps most baffling how are these
kids supposed to travel internationally
in order to track down every witch in
the world and turn them into mice
charlie acts as though sending children
out as international assassins is a
totally reasonable thing to do
but we have more than a few questions
about who these kids are and how they're
going to pull it off successfully
putting aside the logistics of the
child-led mass assassination plan
it's worth realizing that all of the
kids involved are being sent out into
the world to battle supernatural
creatures to the death
sure they're armed with magic potions
but if any of their plans go even
slightly wrong the witches will swoop
down to try to kill them and they will
very likely succeed
young viewers aren't likely to pick up
on the potentially horrific implications
of sending out swarms of children to
engage in life-or-death combat with
super-powered creatures but adults
surely will
you could be optimistic and assume an
overwhelmingly high success rate but
that doesn't seem likely considering how
many hiccups charlie's own plan hit
along the way
so it's likely that at least a few of
these children will get caught and
subsequently eaten
it's possible that charlie doesn't
realize this he's just a teenager after
all
or perhaps he thinks a few kids lives
are a reasonable price to pay to achieve
his goals
and that's not exactly someone you'd
want leading you into battle
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one